we've somewhat already discussed the
topic of divine law and the pragmatic
and unbiased approach taken by thermos
when creating the laws that mankind and
the gods governed by but today we'll be
focusing on the goddess nemesis and her
drastically different view on punishment
and retribution nemesis was the goddess
that would enact retribution against
those who performed evil deeds or whom
she perceived as heaven undeserved good
fortune like so many of the most ancient
deities within Greek mythology nemesis
was just one of the many children of NYX
and although she was mostly depicted as
having no father there are those who
believe that her father could have been
anyone from Oceanus to Erebus to perhaps
even Zeus nemesis went by several names
including RAM Lucia the goddess of ramus
an ancient coastal city in Greece and
perhaps the most fitting atlas Thea
meaning the inescapable we can assume
referring to her inescapable wrath and
retribution the named nemesis itself was
thought to mean she who distributes or
deals out once again referring to her
distribution of punishment justice and
retribution the children of nemesis are
a fairly debated topic Helen of Troy is
widely regarded to be the daughter of
Zeus and the mortal woman leader but
there are tales where it was instead
nemesis that was considered Helens
mother in a last-ditch attempt to avoid
the advances of Zeus nemesis turned
herself into an animal that animals a
goose but Zeus been the ever persistent
God that he was transformed himself into
a swan and mated of nemesis nemesis in
this bird form would lay an egg an egg
that will be later found by a shepherd
who in turn will to give this egg to
leader leader would keep this egg in a
chest until it hatched and when it did
she would raise her love Troy and assume
the role of her mother
nemesis was seen as being able to
measure one's happiness she could see
whether that happiness was too frequent
or too excessive and if she deemed that
in some way this happiness was
undeserved she would bring loss and
suffering to even up the scales there's
no doubt that the actions of Nemesis
still appeared to be somewhat calculated
but nowhere near the level of thermus
nemesis was still known to act swiftly
with no pity or mercy we can see nemesis
as directing human affairs in a way that
maintains the equilibrium those
exploiting others or shown excessive
hubris towards the gods would be very
quickly dealt with often falling back in
line she was particularly known to
concern herself with matters of love and
she makes an appearance in the famous
story of echo and narcissus narcissus
was extremely beautiful but along with
his beauty he was also extremely
arrogant hating all those that dare to
fall in love with him this arrogance
angered nemesis and so she lured him
into a pool where he could see his own
reflection in the river and upon doing
so he felt instantly in love with the
image he saw not knowing that was in
fact his own unable to leave the beauty
that was his own reflection he would
eventually die
the beauty that narcissus was gifted was
seen by nemesis as undeserved and the
way he treated those who dare to fall in
love with him was enough for the goddess
to intervene and in her punishment
eventually caused his death nemesis
would often be depicted as a winged
goddess undoubtedly because it would
make escape in her pursuit almost
impossible the ancient Greek poet
Messner madhi's wrote a hymn to nemesis
where he addressed her as nemesis winged
balancer of life dark faced goddess
daughter of Justice she was known to
carry with her a sword a lash in a
dagger to enact punishment but she would
also carry scales measuring rod and a
bridle that she would sometimes use to
ride her griffin drawn chariot
nemesis was a deity in Greek mythology
that almost had free rein to do as she
pleased the gods weren't really known to
punish mortals unless it was to make an
example of particular individuals this
role of punishment and enforcing the law
amongst mortals thought to a handful of
goddesses who for the most part did as
they were instructed by thermus nemesis
being the goddess of revenge and
retribution was of course the exception
she would punish anyone who was seen as
disrespecting the gods and she was even
seen as delivering good and bad fortune
I'd love to hear what you think about
Nemesis do you feel that her vigilante s
role was necessary or do you prefer the
approach that they mistook when
delivering justice let me know in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explain
[Music]
you